Joaquin Phoenix may play a man with an
uncontrollable cackle and director Todd
Phillips is Joker but he certainly
wasn't laughing in an interview about
the dark and gritty comic book movie
Phoenix ooh stars has failed comedian
Arthur Fleck in the Joker origin story
film released in on October 4th sat down
for an interview with The Telegraph's
Robbie Colin during the conversation
Colin asked Phoenix if he was worried
that his performance might inspire
real-world copycat killers the question
apparently took Phoenix by surprise
causing the actor to briefly walk out at
the interview Colin described what
happened
unlike Heath Ledger's inscrutable take
on the character in 2008's The Dark
Knight Phoenix's Arthur Fleck a failed
comedian who still lives with his
elderly mother is the horribly familiar
enemy within if the film hadn't been set
in the 80s he could easily be the latest
online message for extremists to take
his grievances murderously viral yet
phoenix doesn't seem to have considered
this kind of question at all so when I
put it to him aren't you worried that
this bill might perversely end up
inspiring exactly the kind of people
it's about with potentially tragic
results his fight-or-flight response
kicks in Phoenix reportedly replied why
why would you no no according to Colin
Phoenix then stood up shook his hand and
left the interview roughly an hour later
largely spent talking with Warner
Brothers PR team Phoenix returned to
finish the interview the actor explained
that he left because he had never
considered the possibility and needed
time to try and figure out an
appropriate response but the interview
concluded without being accessory in the
question and it's a question that many
critics are already asking though most
reviewers gave Joker high marks after
its worldwide debut at the Venice
International Film Festival on October
31st 2019 more than one also suggested
that the film may send a dangerous
message and give viewers the wrong idea
about avenging their own personal
grievances Vanity Fair critic Richard
Lawson wondered in his review of Joker
whether the film quote may be
irresponsible propaganda for the very
men it pathologize 'as Stephanie's a
Herrick at time felt that Arthur Fleck
comes across uncomfortably similar to
some of the most violent dangerous
people who have inflicted incredible
harm to people particularly in America
she wrote in part all of Arthur's
travails are leading up to a series of
see what you made me do brutal
most of which happened while he's
dressed up in his clown suits violence
makes him feel more in control less
pathetic killing empowers him the movie
Lion Isis and glamorizes Arthur even as
it shakes its head post sorrowfully over
his violent behavior Collin himself
tweeted after watching Joker at the
Venice Film Festival that he thinks the
movie is good but he's quote worried
someone's going to get killed because of
it he stated in his full review
published by The Telegraph this is a
film that's going to stir up trouble in
the consciousnesses of everyone who
watches it and almost certainly in the
outside world as well when I was a
little boy and told people I was going
to be a comedian everyone laughed at me
well no one's laughing now other critics
though have defended the film the
outlines
Alex Nichols argued that the idea of
Joker's violence potentially resulting
in real-life tragedies quotes rests
entirely on the assumption that violent
media breeds violent behavior Steven
Galloway of The Hollywood Reporter
agreed
arguing that the only people who would
be inspired to violence are people
predisposed to it already he said
there's no evidence to show that a
criminal even one who imitates something
on film wouldn't have done something
equally abominable at another time it
seems like this type of complexity and
ambiguity may have been one of the
biggest reasons why Phoenix signed on
for Joker in the first place as the
actor told Colin after coming back for
the interview he liked that arthur flack
as a character quote posed questions
with no easy answers decide how you feel
about joker when the film opens in
theaters on october 4 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]